(La India
es la democracia más grande del mundo con
más de 1300 millones de habitantes.
Hablamos de un aliado de Estados Unidos, un
aliado cada vez más importante.
Y quizás por eso durante el foro de la Organización
de Cooperación de Shanghái, el Primer Ministro
indio, Narendra Modi le ha reprochado a Putin
la intervención en Ucrania.
(“El primer ministro indio Modi le dice
a la Rusia de Putin que no es tiempo de guerras.
Reuters)
Sin embargo, al mismo tiempo, en el día a
día, la India no se ha sumado a las sanciones
contra Rusia.
Y además, fijaos.)
(India importa 50 veces más petróleo ruso
desde Abril)
¡Habéis oído bien!
Tan pronto como empezó la invasión rusa
de Ucrania, India empezó a comprar petróleo
ruso como si no hubiera mañana… y no hablamos
de una subida pequeña: casi 50 veces más
zumo de dinosaurio de lo que importaban antes.
¡Por supuesto!
India no es el único país que ha hecho caso
omiso de las sanciones económicas
Pensad que el petróleo es la base de la economía
rusa.
Si todos los países dejáramos de comprar
petróleo a Rusia, apenas podrían continuar
la guerra de Ucrania.
Es decir, que el hecho de que India compre
tanto petróleo a Rusia, de la noche a la
mañana…
podría ser todo un balón de oxígeno para
Moscú…
¿O tal vez no?
Luego lo veremos ¿Pero sabéis qué es lo
más curioso de todo?
Que pese a todo esto,la India sigue estrechando
sus lazos con Estados Unidos ¿No me creéis?
Pues atentos.
(Estados Unidos busca incrementar la venta
de armas a la India en mitad de las sanciones
rusas)
Lo sé ¡Os ha estallado la cabeza!
¿Verdad?
Para que os hagáis una idea, desde que empezó
la Guerra de Ucrania, Joe Biden se ha reunido
dos veces con su homólogo Indio: Narendra
Modi.
Y en ambos casos, Biden ha dicho lo mismo:
“Ay!
Narendra Modi…
¡Eso de comprar petróleo a Rusia está muy
feo!
¿Te parece bonito?
¿No ves lo que está haciendo Putin en Ucrania?
¡Me parece muy mal!
Anda, toma 500 millones de dólares para que
te compres armas…
¡Pero no te lo mereces!”
Literalmente: Estados Unidos está preparando
un paquete de ayuda militar de 500 millones
de dólares para la India.
(EE.UU. busca alejar a la India de las armas
rusas con un paquete de ayuda armamentística.
Un posible acuerdo de 500 millones de dólares
pondría a la India cerca de Israel y Egipto.
India es el mayor comprador de material militar
ruso.
Bloomberg)
Y todo esto, pese a que India está haciendo
caso omiso de las sanciones contra Rusia.
Y la pregunta es ¿Por qué?
¿Por qué la India apoya a Rusia en esta
guerra?
¿De verdad India puede salvar la economía
rusa de las sanciones de Occidente?
Y lo que es más importante ¿Y por qué,
pese a todo esto, Estados Unidos sigue colaborando
con India en cosas tan importantes como la
defensa?
Hoy vamos a responder a estas preguntas
pero antes… vamos a ver un poco de historia.
ENTRE DOS MUNDOS)
Desde el año 1955, India ha pertenecido al
tercer mundo.
Literalmente.
La expresión “tercer mundo” se empezó
a usar en la conferencia de Bandung, en 1955.
En esta conferencia, se unieron todos los
países que no querían tomar partido en la
Guerra Fría.
Si el bloque capitalista era el primer mundo,
el bloque comunista el segundo mundo…
ellos serían el tercer mundo.
En esta lista estaban países como Indonesia,
Yugoslavia y…
¡La india!
Pensadlo bien: tras la independencia, la India
tenía un sistema híbrido entre los dos grandes
bloques.
Desde el punto de vista político, India es
una democracia liberal como cualquier otro
país occidental.
Ahora bien, desde el punto de vista económico,
India está muy lejos del capitalismo.
En muchos casos, han llegado a tener incluso
planes quinquenales.
Es decir, era un país llamado a entenderse
con los dos bloques.
(Además, a diferencia de Occidente, la Unión
Soviética siempre estuvo del lado de India
en temas clave para este país.
Por ejemplo, en todas las votaciones de la
ONU, siempre han apoyado a India en su conflicto
con Pakistán en Cachemira.
A este respecto, Estados Unidos tiene una
postura mucho más ambivalente ¿Y qué me
decís del programa nuclear Indio?
En 1974, India hizo el primer ensayo de su
bomba nuclear.
Estados Unidos respondió con sanciones económicas.
Rusia, sin embargo, empezó a suministrar
agua pesada y asesoría nuclear a la India.)
¡Pero esperad un momento porque la cosa no
se queda en la diplomacia!
También hablamos de armamento.
Y, creedme, esto es el pilar básico de la
amistad entre India y Rusia.
Para que os hagáis una idea, hasta el año
2016, el 69% de las importaciones de armamento
de la India venían de la Madre Rusia.
¡Por supuesto!
Como buen país no alineado, Nueva Delhi también
ha comprado armas a otros países, incluido
Estados Unidos.
Sin embargo, su principal proveedor con mucha
diferencia es Rusia.
Y os preguntaréis ¿Por qué?
Pues la principal razón es…
¡Por que son más baratas!
Simple y llanamente: el armamento ruso puede
tener muchos defectos… pero en lo que a
precio se refiere es super competitivo
Y como os podéis imaginar, no sólo hablamos
de armas sino también de piezas para repararlas.
El 80% de las piezas de recambio del arsenal
Indio vienen de Rusia.
Y la lista continúa.
(Podemos también hablar del sector energético.Sí,
es cierto, la India apenas utiliza gas en
su mix energético.
Sólo el 6% de la electricidad de este país
viene del gas.
Sin embargo, en 2019 el gobierno indio y la
empresa estatal rusa ROSATOM alcanzaron un
acuerdo de intenciones para construir al menos
6 nuevos reactores nucleares.
De momento, la empresa rusa está construyendo
el quinto y el sexto reactor de la central
de Kudankulam, una de las principales centrales
del país.)
En otras palabras: las relaciones entre India
y Rusia siempre han sido muy estrechas.
De hecho, 6 de cada 10 indios apoyan que su
Gobierno mantenga lazos con Moscú…
pese a la guerra.
Ahora bien ¿Hablamos de un apoyo convencido…?
¿O de simple interés económico?
Pues bien, ahora mismo lo vamos a ver.
T2(UN PASO AL ESTE, DOS AL OESTE)
En el año 2014, Narendra Modi se convirtió
en el Primer Ministro de la India.
Y muchos diréis ¿Pero quién es Narendra
Modi?
¿Cuál es su ideología?
Podríamos decir que Modi es un líder populista,
muy nacionalista y absolutamente popular entre
sus ciudadanos.
Para que os hagáis una idea, su partido ocupa
más del 60% de los escaños de la cámara
baja.
Vamos, que poder no le falta ¿Y qué ideología
profesa este hombre?
Pues, por resumir, podríamos decir que el
programa de Modi se fundamenta en 3 pilares:
por un lado tenemos el ultranacionalismo.
Al lado de Narendra Modi, Donald Trump parecería
un progre abraza árboles.
El segundo pilar de su gobierno es la tecnocracia:
Modi llegó al poder con la promesa de acabar
con la hiper burocratización de la India
¿Lo ha conseguido?
Pues… es bastante discutible.
Sin embargo, el tercer pilar del Gobierno
de Modi no es otro que…
¡Estrechar lazos con Occidente!
Y, creedme, en este sentido, la diplomacia
de Narendra Modi ha tenido bastantes luces.
Pese a ser más Trumpista que el propio Trump,
Modi fue amigo personal de Barack Obama ¡Es
más!
Obama llegó a escribirle un perfil para la
revista TIME donde parecía que le declaraba
amor eterno.
Por supuesto, durante la administración Trump,
Nueva Delhi y Washington se entendieron sin
problema.
Y diréis…
más allá de las palabras ¿Qué significa
eso de “acercarse a Occidente”?
Pues, entre otras cosas, significa hacer todo
tipo de alianzas de seguridad ¿Por qué?
Pues muy simple: para defenderse de uno de
los mayores adversarios de la India ¿De quién
estoy hablando?
¿De Pakistán?
¡NO!
De otro mucho más poderoso y más temible:
China.
Eso explica, por ejemplo, que INDIA forme
parte del QUAD: una alianza estratégica que
incluye a Estados Unidos, Australia, Japón
y la India.
Pero… de nuevo, no sólo hablamos de diplomacia:
también hablamos de hechos.
Más concretamente de… ¡Armamento!
Vamos a ser claros: las armas rusas son baratas
porque fallan más que una escopeta de feria.
Si a alguien le quedaba alguna duda, no tiene
nada más que pasarse por Ucrania o ver el
vídeo que dedicamos aquí, en VisualPolitik,
al complejo militar industrial Ruso.
Como os podéis imaginar, con un arsenal tan
defectuoso, es difícil disuadir a una China
cada vez más poderosa ¿Conclusión?
India necesita poder echar mano del armamento
occidental.
Y, creedme… en este sentido, Modi no está
perdiendo el tiempo.
Echad un vistazo a esta gráfica.
(Para que os hagáis una idea; antes de 2016,
casi el 70% de las importaciones de armas
venían de Rusia.
Ahora son menos del 30%.
Francia ya está vendiendo cazas de combate
RAFALE y MIRAGE.)
Y ya sé lo que estaréis pensando todos:
¿No habíamos dicho que las armas de Estados
Unidos son muy caras?
Pues sí.
Son carísimas.
Y la India no tiene tanto dinero ¿Entonces
cuál es la solución?
(Pues la solución consiste, por ejemplo,
en crear joint ventures con empresas Indias.
Es decir, un fabricante americano firma un
acuerdo con otro indio para producir juntos
un avión con muchos ahorros de coste y quizás
más limitado que las versiones norteamericanas,
pero mucho más efectivo en cualquier caso
que los rusos.)
Ahora bien, ¿Cuál es el problema con este
tipo de acuerdos?
El problema es que la India sigue siendo un
país muy centralizado: la industria armamentística
está dominada por gigantes estatales hiper
burocratizados.
Empresas como, por ejemplo, Hindustan Aeronautics
Limited.
Y eso explica que, en en el año 2020, Modi
abriera la puerta a la inversión extranjera,
que ahora pueden tener hasta el 74% de la
propiedad de una empresa de armas.
Y, creedme, esta medida ya está empezando
a dar efectos.
Atentos.
(Lockheed Martin y Tata Advanced Systems firman
un acuerdo donde unen fuerzas para producir
el F-16 Block 70 en la India)
Sin embargo…
Cambiar todo tu arsenal es algo que no se
puede hacer de la noche a la mañana.
Rusia sigue siendo crucial para la India tanto
en defensa como en energía.
Y por eso, Modi ha decidido no sancionar a
Rusia ¿Es una buena idea?
¿Es una mala idea?
Desde luego, desde VisualPolitik no podemos
aplaudirle.
Pero una cosa es cierta, la India está sacando
mucho provecho a la situación.
(India intenta diversificar sus fuentes de
energía con petróleo ruso barato)
Para que os hagáis una idea, ANTES de la
guerra, Rusia sólo suponía un 0,5% del petróleo
Indio.
Ahora es más del 10%.
En abril de 2021, India compró unos 22.500
barriles de petróleo al día rusos.
En abril de 2022, la cifra estaba por encima
de los 680.000.
Y ya estará el listo de turno diciendo…
¡Aha!
¿Ves?
¡Así es como Rusia puede crecer pese a las
sanciones!
¿Verdad?
En lugar de vender petróleo a los europeos,
ahora se lo vende a los indios, que son muchos
más ¿Verdad?
Pues… no.
En realidad, quien realmente ha hecho el business
aquí es Nueva Delhi¡Atentos a la jugada!
Como Estados Unidos y Europa están dejando
de comprar zumo de dinosario a Rusia, el precio
se ha inflado hasta niveles nachovidalianos.
En algunos momentos, el barril de Brent ha
llegado a superar los 120 dólares.
Sin embargo, ningún país rico quiere comprar
petróleo a Rusia.
Y ahí es cuando llega la India y dice “¡Hombreeee…
mi amigo, mi camarada, mi tobarich…!
Tranquilo que aquí estoy yo para comprarte
petróleo… pero, ya que soy casi el único
comprador…
¿Me lo dejarás a precio de amigo, no?
¿Qué te parece un descuento de 30 dólares
por barril?”.
Y a Rusia no le queda más remedio que pasar
por el aro.
Dicho de otra forma, India ha estado comprando
petróleo muy por debajo del precio de mercado.
Dicho de otra forma: en este negocio hay poco
de ideología o amistad y mucho de aprovechar
la situación ¡No sólo eso!
Europa importaba más de 3.1 millones de barriles
rusos al día.
Esto es antes de la guerra.
India está comprando alrededor de 680.000
barriles al día.
Es decir, que en el caso de que Europa dejara
de comprar petróleo a Rusia (cosa bastante
probable), India no va a poder compensar las
pérdidas.
Ni por precio ni por cantidad.
Pero ahora la pregunta es…
¿Por qué Biden sigue estrechando la cooperación
con la India?
Ahora mismo lo vamos a ver.
T3(EL COLLAR DE PERLAS)
Más allá de Rusia, la mayor amenaza contra
la seguridad de Occidente es China.
Y, en este sentido, los intereses de la India
no podían estar más alineados con Occidente.
En este sentido, India tiene mucho que perder.
Pensad que China y la India tienen disputas
fronterizas de todo tipo.
Cada pocos años hay alguna escaramuza en
la frontera del Himalaya.
Pero, sin duda alguna, la peor amenaza es…
Atentos a este mapa.
(Lo que estáis viendo aquí es la estrategia
del Collar de Perlas.
Es decir, una serie de puertos financiados
por China y colocados estratégicamente para
llegado el caso poder rodear a la India.
Hablamos de puertos en Pakistán, Sri Lanka
y Bangladesh.
En principio, estos puertos están pensados
para uso civil…
¡Pero están pagados por China!
Y tanto Pakistan como Sri Lanka o Bangladesh
son economías muy débiles así que en un
momento dado China podría presionarles para
operar desde ellos su armada.)
Durante años, China ha estado ejerciendo
lo que aquí, en VisualPolitik, llamamos la
diplomacia Sugar Daddy.
Lo hemos explicado varias veces en anteriores
vídeos.
En resumen: China puede convertir esos puertos
en uso militar de forma muy sencilla.
Y eso es toda una amenaza para la seguridad
de la India.
Eso explica todas las alianzas diplomáticas
y militares de Nueva Delhi con Washington.
Y diréis ¿Qué puede aportar la India para
disuadir a China?
¡Pues mucho!
Principalmente una cosa: la geografía.
Atentos a este otro mapa.
Esto que véis aquí es el estrecho de Malaca.
Uno de los epicentros del comercio mundial.
Más del 70% del gas y el p etróleo que llega
a China pasa por aquí.
Bastaría con cortar el tránsito de barcos
un día para que los chinos colapsaran de
un momento a otro ¿Y qué países podrían
cortar este tráfico?
¡Exacto!
La India.
Y diréis ¿Cómo podrían hacerlo?
Pues muy simple ¿Veis estas otras islas de
aquí?
Estas son las islas de Andaman y Nicobar.
Un archipiélago prácticamente desabitado.
Hasta hace años, sólo era conocido por las
tribus indígenas que lo habitaban.
Ahora, sin embargo, las cosas están cambiando
y mucho por aquí.
Atentos.
(La nueva base naval en las islas Andamán
impulsa la posición militar de la India en
el Océano Índico)
Y todo esto explica que Estados Unidos esté
tan interesado en mejorar los lazos con la
India.
En este respecto, lo que hagan con Rusia está
en un segundo plano.
El interés de Washington es que Nueva Delhi
tenga un buen ejército listo para disuadir
a China.
Todo lo demás es secundario.
Además…
¿Hasta qué punto es tan crucial que la India
compre petróleo a Rusia?
Pensadlo bien, en el momento en el que hacemos
este vídeo, el debate con la India está
en el tope al precio del petróleo.
Muchos países del G7: es decir, las mayores
economías del mundo, quieren fijar un precio
máximo al petróleo ruso.
Para que eso llegara a funcionar, todas principales
economías deberían ponerse de acuerdo.
Y parece que India no está dispuesta a unirse.
Al menos, en el momento en el que hacemos
este vídeo.
La pregunta es…
¿De verdad marca una gran diferencia?
Pensadlo bien: Si India compra petróleo a
Rusia es porque YA se lo están vendiendo
muy por debajo del precio de mercado.
Es decir, que con o sin tope de gasto, India
sólo está interesada en el zumo de dinosaurio
siberiano…
si se lo venden barato.
Conclusión: por el momento, no parece que
Washington esté muy preocupado con que India
haga negocio de la guerra de Ucrania.
Lo importante, en este caso, es la postura
con China.
Y llegados a este punto, ahora las preguntas
son: ¿Creéis que India llegará a renovar
todo su arsenal con armas occidentales?
¿Sería buena idea presionar a la India para
que se una a las sanciones contra Rusia?
Podéis dejarme vuestra respuesta en los comentarios.
Como siempre, no olvidéis que aquí, en VisualPolitik,
sacamos vídeos nuevos todas las semanas así
que suscribíos a este canal y dadle a la
campanita para no perderos ninguna de nuestras
actualizaciones.
Si os ha gustado este vídeo, dadle a LIKE
y nos vemos en el próximo.
Un abrazo y hasta pronto.